you had a hard time getting into
directing in in other words you were you
were a guy
you were one of the cast of happy days
everyone thought you couldn't direct
well especially people coming from
sitcoms and directing movies i mean that
was just a ridiculous leap as far as
anybody was were you so desperate that
and i read this that you wanted to get
into porno in order to finance your
first film at one at one time
actually i want to see i bet you'd be a
really good porno well i talked to
cheryl we have a good production
and charles said i don't think so i
think so right but i said you know
actually it was it was right at the time
that behind the green door
and a deep throat were making like
gazillion millions of dollars right
and it was the first wave of the
independent filmmaking movement right
and i read something that francis
coppola had like been a sound guy on
pornos or something before he did
godfather and all these movies right
and i thought and no one was taking me
seriously about directing i could just
see it they were just so patronizing it
was right
yeah well they're like hey it's opie
yeah right and i actually thought one
day i said you know
maybe i can cash in on this thing one
time one shot
opie gets laid right you make it you own
it
you know what does it cost 15. you would
have started the film start in the movie
right wow
you were desperate to get laid right
back to that
right yeah i wanted the money to be
independent as a filmmaker
okay so you thought about going
door-to-door you said you were
door-to-door for a year
and and get a dollar from everybody get
a dollar from everybody you wanted to go
on during happy days buy a commercial
and say would everyone send me a dollar
send me a dollar wow you would just i've
entertained you over the years please
now send me a dollar
i found out that that's illegal but the
for it is you can't do that robin
scratching that idea i was gonna do that
you're kidding me a couple of times
already i was desperate right desperate
to become a director
so so you did it by your first movie was
like a six hundred thousand dollar
budget and it made a couple of mil
it did made six million what was the
name of that grand theft auto grand
theft auto right
hmm i got it yeah oh please you don't
want to miss grand theft
auto is it bad it's pretty goofy
it is but it made money thank god
actually you got pretty good reviews at
the time because if it didn't make money
then you would have that that might have
been
in the end well if you know if i just
screwed that up it would have been bad
right
so then once you get that you get to
make your next picture what was your
next picture after that
well then everybody said okay he can
direct movies so then all the studios
started offering me
the same movie i got seven scripts that
were now you gotta realize this is 1978
right seven really badly written scripts
about a gonzo group of kooks
flying pot in from you know from tj
right and you know the wacky plane
flight and
you you couldn't relate to that i just i
just felt like those weren't going to be
very good
right so what was the next film i
started doing tv movies
right that i uh that i uh owned
and and produced as well as directed and
then i did three of those
wow which is actually the first time i
met brian grazer oh i see and then you
guys teamed up
and we teamed up then then brian grazer
came to me with this idea night shift
right and it was that was a cool movie
two guys running a a prostitution ring
out of the new york city morgue kevin
costner was an extra on that
he was can you believe that yeah i
didn't even remember this i didn't
remember this i
we needed somebody to come in and and
michael keaton was like he was at you
know ad libbing like crazy coming up
with great stuff and i said you know
we're going to do this scene this party
scene naked women it's in the morgue
i need somebody that he can talk to
they're supposed to be these frat boys
running around in there
right and uh so i need some actors so
jane jenkins the casting director said
here here's a guy this guy really needs
a job right
great guy he's got no money right would
you hire this guy
and i said uh i looked it for two
seconds the eight by ten i said yeah
okay fine
really and uh he came in and whoever it
was did fine i didn't think anything of
it
and about whenever untouchables came out
and then you know dances with wolves and
all these things
right somebody said you know kevin
costner was in night shift i said where
yeah i don't remember him i don't
remember and i actually bumped into him
and uh and i said night shift right he
said yeah night shift and i
from the smile i couldn't tell whether
like i was a jerk
right right yeah you know
[ __ ] about it all right right yeah
and he said uh and i said
was i nice to you you were great you
were great so i breathed a little
cyberleaf
oh i see yeah so so so uh that movie
made it big
and then after that then it was no
problem then you came out with like
splash and cocoon and all that
was still a problem was a huge problem
why is that a problem
we had this script same writers gans and
mandel right
and uh and it was funny but there was
this other movie this other mermaid
movie
right that warren beatty was was was
gonna do with jessica lange and herbert
ross was directing and ray stark and
this was all when everybody was like
absolutely
you know hitting on all cylinders
dominating the business right and they
had a mermaid movie that they just
announced we might do a mermaid movie
oh no and no studio would do our movie
everybody was just turning it down left
and right oh no kidding
every and finally we went so we went to
disney brian calls me up
yeah and says okay we got one last
meeting it's at disney now the last
movie disney put out at that time was
gus
the field goal kicking mule right yeah
because he was not the disney of today
for michael eisenberg yeah they didn't
make great movies and i said oh my god
you know the first thing we're down to
disney
we're down to disney and they're going
to want to they're going to like not
they're going to put like a like a
a big top on her you know she's probably
gonna be like a full-covered mermaid
right right right it's really gonna be
ridiculous talking fish
yeah well you could re-team with barney
fight right i thought that would be a
good idea that you know
that's what they'd want to do but but
brian said we got it we got to go in and
sell it to him
so i got caught up in just the heat of
selling you know right brian knows how
to wind me up
right because this is the hard part of
the business you want to just make
movies
yeah but you got to go get someone to
finance exactly right so they said what
about this other movie and at a certain
point
and i i had been through the whole thing
and i said she's got to be topless and
you know it'll be still be pg-13 i won't
let her did you have daryl hannah in
mind for that role
uh yeah but she was the one you wanted
beautiful beautiful
you are like mother teresa
you